la Coupe du Monde version française
c'est également dotée d'une belle
mascotte qui conjugue vous allez le voir
le football et la gauloiserie son nom
footix il fallait y penser voyons cela
avec Didier Chaumont
je m'appelle désormais footix c'est fier
d'être Gaulois je serai sur tous les
stades de France pour vous faire vibrer
pendant la coupe du monde 98 pour
participer à cette grande fête il ne
vous suffit pas d'acheter la mascotte
encore faut-il posséder le précieux
sésame le billet passe France 98 mais en
vente aujourd'hui dans les 2500 agences
du Crédit Agricole impossible de savoir
encore quelle équipe jouera sur quel
stade mais les premiers arrivés seront
les premiers servis ce Pass 98 vous en
coûtera de 725 à 2250 francs je suis
venu offrir un cadeau de Noël de mon
fils c'est à dire un passe pour la Coupe
du monde dans deux ans
donc pour le moment je n'achète 4 mais
il est pas dit que j'enverrai pas ma
mère et mon frère et ma femme après en
acheter quatre